what it's like for you because you've
been grinding independently for so long
what has been the biggest thing that
you've learned since coming with CMG
because obviously you know I always say
it like the hottest label in the world
you know what I'm saying like it's
really like the modern day death Rowan
so for you coming into such a it's like
the All-Star team yeah you know what I
mean it's crazy when you really go
through the roster what is some stuff
you've picked up
the future matters you know what I'm
saying but the brand you know what I'm
saying that's it build the brand you
know what I'm saying like
right now you see how you saying like
CMG and and got it got his artist you
feel me he making sure that that them
artists building their brand in the
process and you know what I'm saying
you know when he feel me don't get no
better than that you know what I'm
saying the brand that's all that matter
having something in the years from now
there's no I'm saying that that's still
here you're feeling like he did
I like that